all right guys i'm gonna start us off
with a little
a little uh over the hills and far away
yes please
take us there
[Music]
now
you just can't help but sing it can you
i was waiting for somebody else to jump
in but nobody did i didn't i don't know
it oh yeah i don't even yeah
we're young we're little youngsters
hey
i mean we did the whole like hearing
stairway to heaven for the first time
reaction video
jordan led zeppelin okay
yeah they basically invented the metal
genre before metal was a thing
just listen to led zeppelin albums one
through four
and
you know you're good to go
like for the rest of my life i mean i
will still have to by the way
yes i need to as well if you've never
done that um i would highly recommend it
or that one live album they had how the
west was one i think that was it yeah
hollywest was one they have a great uh
video concert um called the song remains
the same that was uh shot in new york
city at madison square garden 1977.
um they played two nights it's amazing
and uh
yeah just remember when robert plant the
lead singer
uh recorded the first album he was i
think 18 or 19 years old so
geez you know don't give up hope um
i mean that just makes me feel bad more
than anything
right i know that's like almost there
jimmy page the guitarist was a studio
musician um prior to him joining and uh
when they said that he was forming a new
band someone in a
record
publication said that his new band was
gonna
was gonna drop like a led zeppelin and
then they they took it off
so led zeppelin's a whole band or a
person whole band
it's okay i didn't want to ask
you you have to ask these really yeah so
it's a whole it's a whole band
just just remember pink floyd pink floyd
okay there's no one named pink in the
band
yeah okay yeah that makes sense the lead
singer isn't pink
[Music]
i thought it was rolling and stone like
hauling oats but i also thought hall and
oates was hauling oats
this was what we did before we became
musicians we were hauling oats i thought
the guy that he just glued nickels to
his back
thank you yeah thank you he did actually
he did he did can we keep this up
i don't know how much longer we want to
keep
this for a long time was he called when
he pressed player
guys
ludicrous guys this is ludicrous stop it
there was a guy named luda christian
yeah
he's probably says some pretty crazy
stuff doesn't it yeah we'll say it as
lyrics he's probably going off the rails
on a crazy train yeah no doubt
all right all right seriously we're done
we're done we're done anyone get it
jordan anybody need to get out any other
jobs 20 of them
yeah i showed her some restraint here oh
i don't know i don't know what that
means
i'm showing after strength
all right so a couple things to talk
about we shot a saber video um i also
wanted to talk maybe if we get to it a
little bit about wizard cops i i jotted
down some ideas um so maybe we can joke
about those yeah and the cat's out of
the bag too on that new ronin 4d as well
that's right so
yeah where do you want to start
start the saber video
okay yeah yeah so i've you know uh
if someone happens to listen to this
podcast and they don't watch either the
quarter crew channel the quarter channel
or follow us on instagram you gotta let
us know
we're talking to you those same people
that we shouted out last time on the
podcast
but i'm sure all you all know that we
dropped this lightsaber video
technically not a lightsaber video
energy swords um
i dropped the saber video over the
weekend here we've been working out for
a little chunk of time here
um it was nice to get back into doing
some cinema
some narrative some storytelling and
also you know we we talked the talk
quite a bit on sutton react and vfx
artists react but it's nice to get out
there and try to walk the walk for a
minute and see if we could actually make
a nice sword fight that had storytelling
and tension and things like that and
that was you know kind of a bit of a
passion drive from luke lafontaine as
well
is i think he's wanted a reason to go
out and do a sword fight like that
because he knows he has the capability
to choreograph it like that he just
isn't seeing it really in modern cinema
um so really kind of just let him take
the reins and the choreography and
you know we jumped in and as a studio we
knocked out the whole production and and
made it happen um
jordan did some fine acting matt doesn't
find vfx work
uh
yeah jordan also and christian got a
dump truck of production logistics
dumped on them yeah um like a week
jordan what was that like getting
getting blasted with hot takes on the
production front
man trial by five watch the crew cuts
episode
it was um it was a rough week i knew we
were going to get it done though um
christian the whole time was like it's
kind of it's going to happen
he was like i don't get nervous anymore
because he knows what's going to happen
meanwhile i was
oh man i was sweating bullets every
single day i was so scared because there
was so much to get done because what it
was started off like a three
page
like beat sheet i guess and then nico
was like
no
i'm making this into a whole quarter
digital short film and i was like oh
yeah and we like sit down and i just get
this list of things that we need and
amazon's like no no no
it's not going to get there on time
there's a wall to get built there's
people to dress in ghees i never even
knew what a ghee was
i thought it was a guideline
[Laughter]
but it was um it was pretty awesome
seeing everything
come together it's beautiful production
is beautiful yeah you guys did a great
job putting that together i think
you know there's an ethos of you know
just tell the story and i think we did a
solid job of locking that in right to
where it needed to be without overdoing
it because we didn't necessarily have
the time or resources to do so but like
way early on like
so you know we're conceptualizing it and
this was potentially not going to be
lightsabers it's potentially just going
to be regular swords
um
but
i ended up going to spin it towards
lightsabers just because energy swords
look cooler
and it's a little more clickable i mean
if we're gonna talk about like something
that everybody resonates with in pop
culture like everybody knows what a
lightsaber is
um yeah
and so we're putting that together and
part of the reason this was coming
together is because dji had approached
us to ask if we would shoot something on
the new camera and we're like sure and
like we had free reign to kind of pick
whatever we wanted which is rare uh so
there's kind of like a well let's do
something cool
there is a challenge when it comes to
these like we call them fully dedicated
videos that's when a brand comes to us
and they're like we have a theme we have
a marketing theme and we want you guys
to
do an idea that fits within the theme
and i'm always we used to take those a
lot more as we've moved on through time
i've become more
like skeptical of them
sort of upfront because what happens is
like you pigeonhole yourself into like
okay here's a great idea and then they
go yeah we like it but can you just kind
of just remove the thing that makes it a
good idea
and that happens
so much yeah um and so but dji
has we've worked with them in the past
and they've just been
super supportive of like just getting us
the gear getting us the tech
and letting us go with it and so it was
it was kind of a no-brainer on this one
yeah
yeah and
just getting out there and trying to
like this this is the stuff i i
personally like to really do um
and having a reason to go out there and
do it
and you don't have to worry about you're
not trying to make your money back for
sex you're not selling tickets you know
you're not trying to convince people to
give you a dollar to watch a cool scene
um
you can just kind of go out there and do
something you want to do as long as
there's a little that hook that can work
to pull the audience in then that's
awesome
um
but
it was you know when we were kind of
conceptualizing this
sam was one who was like hey nico if
you're gonna try to make something look
good so you can show off that this
camera looks nice
just get a good location get a good
location everything else like
will do its thing
and i was like here that's that's a
great idea sam and the thing is
locations in l.a are really expensive so
you kind of need like you need a reason
to just go for it and sam kind of like
pushed me over that edge otherwise i'm
pretty frugal and like i don't like to
put too many strings on our budgets in
terms of like overloading with stuff
because i think it's really stressful
um but then i basically turned to
christian like all right christian let's
get a great location because she's like
okay we have
four days
[Laughter]
um and then uh he started searching uh
chase started searching i don't know if
you were in the search too jordan i
think you were yeah um and the thing is
everything's like a minimum like 3000 to
four thousand dollars
and it doesn't like none of these places
would come with lighting and so you're
looking at another couple thousand
dollars in terms of equipment rental
logistics of getting the truck and with
all the gear the crew to set it up the
day before let's just let's just let's
use the timer
for it for a second
a lot of people don't know this um
typically
when you rent a location
the first thing that you're getting in
terms of like the understanding of the
deal is just the space
so whatever they have in the space is
kind of what you get access to and so
for example if they have a warehouse and
they're like yeah we had you know marvel
come through here and they did x y and z
to these walls and then they left and so
they have they they have these cool
walls but there's no lighting there's no
electrical there's no bathrooms there's
no parking there's no
like green room there's no none of that
sometimes that's what you get and so
you're paying just your base fee
sometimes it's like oh well you know two
grand a day or four grand a day i guess
we can do that but then you realize oh
well actually we need to we need to get
a cube truck we need to get
bathrooms we need to get parking when we
need to get drivers and drive people to
and from in so
immediately your costs can just go
yeah um so you just have to be careful
and it's like why are you doing all this
it's like to just tell your story and
it's like does getting a cube truck help
you
make your sword fight look realistic and
it's like
uh he's starting to get pretty far
removed you know as you start having to
rent bathrooms
it's like i could just shoot this in the
street and like because people don't
care too much about the background you
know they want to see the actions as
long as it's believable it's always
believable right obviously it has to
work and it can't be overly distracting
but uh i don't know how the location was
found do you know jordan it was through
that app
this episode is not brought to you by
peer space it's not brought to you by
peer space but peer space worked out in
this case
yeah but christian found this amazing
location that was like half the price of
the others already had lighting already
had cool dressing and like the whole
time i was pushing like the vibe of like
i want like a dojo-esque
clean imagine you're watching the new
dune movie
or blade runner 2049. basically just
let's rip off denny
villanuev
villanueva oh boy
denise
i don't know
what's up the name anyways we're on a
first name
yeah so
we got that location locked down and
then kind of almost everything else fell
into place
around that uh ultra sabres
uh overnighted us the props um they
worked great they were super durable
like they're just sturdy
uh jordan whipped together all the
costumes they had a power outage in the
studio when all this was happening we
were doing rehearsals
but it ended up all coming together uh
really really well and of course like
this is a camera that we've never used
before really i mean obviously we've
played with it and matt used it yeah and
actually there was a little bit of like
we got lucky there because we did have
it for like two months before we even
shot this so we had time to play with it
um yeah me and ren like i was operating
that camera for a good month before we
even shot it so i was pretty familiar
with it um nico got super familiar with
it as well um
yeah
yeah you were messing around with it
before you know you had you had time
you're like chasing us around this video
like all right run over here
like when you roll into a production
where like everything's coming together
for that one day with an untested beta
piece of hardware it can be really
really risky yeah because you can go
down like something crashes something
doesn't work and then you are like your
day is shot yeah right yeah i don't know
if we want to get into too much detail
but we we did have a beta version of the
product and that did happen after we had
filmed right this is because i screwed
up
a thing that was the firmware like to be
fair was it wasn't like we were
recording something and stopped just
because i screwed something up
um
when they're like hey we have brand new
experimental technology you can't talk
about it we'll send you
one of them
film something awesome with it and then
you're like ah we've never in the
cameras now it's not like you know
they're basically like computers at this
point yeah um so you know
they need to be all synced up with your
firmware and
yeah the programming and everything and
you know if you do something really
weird through the menu maybe it hasn't
been coded in yet
but the camera worked
excellently the like we had zero issues
on set um the picture was great
did you wait did you take the monitor
outside and like walk around the block
with it not on set
i mean to be fair the second day we did
the dialogue i literally just sat on a
couch with the monitor in my lap pulling
focus and then just kind of shouting out
orders at matt and the actors
it was very very comfy yeah
that was a very chill directing day for
you
yeah yeah
yeah but it was really helpful like i
actually got to like get the moments i
needed
to brought the beanbag chair dude
you could really focus on the you know
performance right yeah the storytelling
aspect of it without all the other yeah
technical [ __ ] let's take a little
u-turn here um so in
in la if you want a good actor most of
them are seg aka union
and there's a bunch of minimums that you
have to reach before that's even a thing
you can consider uh so a lot of it is
just out of the question for youtube
productions even like moderately to big
size youtube productions just the seg
thing is it's really tricky unless you
have unless they're big enough where
they can come on your show and be like
hey i'm just gonna go do this
and then seg we'll just be like uh
should we say something no no let's just
leave it but in terms of like just
classic yeah i mean in terms of just
traditional acting especially for all
the working actors who are here in town
um you have it's hard to connect with
them for youtube production so we do a
lot of stuff through like la casting and
actors access and a whole bunch of just
like open casting things where people
who aren't seg um or people who are and
just say screw it
i can you know audition for things
but you end up with a lot of
you end up with a lot of odd
oddballs
you end up with a lot of people who are
very unique who are characters in and of
themselves but they're not necessarily
actors
whoa
hey i didn't see you there i've been
searching the deep dark corners of the
internet looking for the best place to
get all of your stock asset needs and i
finally found it with today's sponsor
storyblocks there it is guys it's the
one stop shop for all your stock asset
needs for creators and businesses alike
they have high quality 4k video audio
images motion graphics after effects
templates and more and it all comes in a
virtually unlimited library making it
such that every time you go on there to
get something
there's something new and with their
unlimited all access plan you can
download as much as you want whenever
you want and use it in commercial
projects personal projects whatever you
need to use it in you can use it in it's
designed to help you to streamline your
process for getting stock assets and to
get them into your project as fast and
efficiently as possible you know i'm
looking through these internet tubes and
i don't see another place that would be
better than storyblocks so if you guys
are interested head on over to
storyblocks.comcast to get started or
click the link in the description below
that's
storyblocks.com
corridorcast
oh look at that i can see you putting
those assets into your project file with
ease
so proud of you
all right well huge thanks to them once
again for sponsoring and now back to the
podcast
imagine imagine an eclectic mix from
cities all over the united states and
the world
coming to a location
with the idea that they're going to be
an actor
and then and then
you know with little to no training and
then
boom like there they are maybe like a
year or two of training yeah it's a yeah
it's a really unique thing um but it
also
uh yeah i mean it's just yeah you can
find diamonds in the rough if you put
the time into it um but more often than
not you're presented a challenge as a
director when you decide to go that
route to figure out how can i get the
best out of this person
in a way that helps the story and helps
the peace without it becoming like
getting bogged down into basically bad
acting
um
and
from all the years of experience we have
had doing this
i've started to create a little like
cheat sheet of like okay here's like my
safe boundaries that i can get with
almost anybody and then like i can add
on to it from there as we go
and like the the thing i've kind of
learned
first and foremost more than anything
else
is cast someone for their voice if they
have to say lines
don't doesn't matter what they look like
you can put costumes and makeup and
lighting and you can do whatever you
want um just cast them for their voice
and it also makes auditions really easy
because you're like you can only give
him the script be like read it into your
phone please and send it back to me and
you just listen to it and hopefully
somebody works and if nobody works well
then you you ask sam to do it
that was our fallback was for sam to be
the
headmaster um
but we we uh we found this guy named
porya um who's our headmaster he had he
had the voice it sounded great
um
and then frankly you know
trying to find a person that has the
look and they have the voice and they
can also act for your characters is
really almost impossible unless you're
gonna like drop the money a lot big
money to like specifically hire a name
actor
you're gonna have a hard time getting
all three of those things to come
together so we kind of made a point of
of filming uh the headmaster like in
this kind of like shrouded anime-esque
like baseball cap pulled down over his
eyes
look and then like as we eased into it
and like you got used to the guy being
there like we revealed more of him but
that was kind of like that was my way to
get us into this piece and have acting
from somebody who's not necessarily
saying just something we found online
and have it be passable is just focus on
the voice
don't worry about the face for a while
and then also just have the plot really
move forwards
and on the other hand you have jordan
who basically just aced all or takes and
i didn't have to worry about anything
thank you
you got a lot of love in the comments
from the acting on that one that was
great i did see the comments it's all
really really nice
[Laughter]
i had a blast
i loved it the guy was like what did do
you act you're so comfortable i was like
i don't know it's like i work here so
maybe that's part of it you're like yeah
sorry i know these fools i don't know
yeah but at the same time i was super
super nervous because when you have
something like you just wrote it and
you're very very passionate about it and
i do work here so i have to see you
every day i were to come there and not
be prepared and
make it hard for you
i wouldn't want to come back the next
day so
yeah i feel like you can't just bomb and
leave like he could have just bombed and
left i can't bomb and leave so i was
like
do it well you did a really good job
jordan i mean
it was it's nice when you're directing
somebody and what you're doing between
takes is
trying different things to see how they
feel and like imagining the scenes your
head versus trying different takes to
find something good and like with you it
wasn't oh i gotta hunt and i gotta hunt
okay now you're hitting something that
sounds like it can work like every
performance you did was good it was more
like okay let's try this version let's
try this version okay this version is
like it's clicking with me like
you know that it's we're playing pretend
more than we were uh just trying to make
it work right and it's nice to be past
that stage of just trying to make it
work i always try to think of like how
you guys would be editing it so if you
have different things to work with and
you can just pick and choose because
there are some reactions that weren't
even actually
the reactions that we took for that
particular scene you could just use it
so i try to just stay fluent in that but
still give you guys other things to be
able to work with yeah it did it was
very helpful i know that would suck as
an editor to be like oh wow every single
take looks the exact same you're just
like all right let me just pick one
instead of being like oh that's the one
i was a little guilty of just
kind of letting you do what you did and
then like
focusing more on porya like trying to
like dial the performance out of him
um versus like
that's the problem i have is like
usually the person who like delivers the
best performances on set gets the fewest
amount it takes
which is something that you know you i
need to work to be doing the opposite of
um
but yeah
it was good it was still worked it
worked it worked right yeah
it's the first video i've had people say
there's good acting in
um
what about all the videos that i've been
in
yeah
so there's that they're all they're all
wanting a number two
yeah they're all wanting it
i do wonder where the story could go i
mean it would be interesting to tell a
big story about like you know all
different things he could do around a
sword school like that'd be cool but
like
in terms of like what's next here i
think i think it inspired a lot of
people's imaginations i didn't
necessarily have anything else planned
in my mind
some people like part two here's a
question for part two
jordan
we cut away to black before you answered
the question
are you gonna join the school
i mean i already started
training did you
there you go
yeah cuts to a cuts to a back alley
and it's just like practicing
yeah and she's like you know it's like a
peter parker tale where she's like
coming up in the world and she's
figuring out this new power that she's
trying to learn she's trying to keep it
a secret from her friends
you know i couldn't afford a lightsaber
so i've just been using my mop yeah
that's right oh yeah it's just the mop
so because of the mop weight it trains
you in a way that no one else has been
trained and therefore
it's the exact weight of a lightsaber
turns out
that's the big twist
someone did throw out the idea of a
slightly different opening where
jordan sees this or hears the starting
like peeks into the room and then sneaks
in and then kind of
runs into the headmaster who's like
standing kind of off in the corner in
the shadows also and like doesn't know
who he is
and like so the idea of her like not
supposed to be there but she's mo like
she's
has a desire to be in there so she
sneaks in she takes the risk
and then like ends up talking to this
guy who's like kind of sitting off in
the corner and then realizes at the end
that he's the one in charge the whole
thing and he's aware that she snuck in
and like you know broke through there'll
be way more anime
yeah
but that's also like that would have
been good
yeah that wasn't a good one
yeah
i saw that too that's yeah it's a good
idea but hey you know you're thinking
about a lot of but he only got that idea
because he's watched the video so yeah
you know
well that's what i'm saying yeah nico's
writing it and thinking about a lot of
different aspects of the story and how
the characters are working together it's
easy to come up with ideas when so yeah
they sparked that idea yeah that's why
being able to reshoot stuff is actually
really nice for making a perfect product
right you know there's there's one funny
thing i noticed with the comments
yes i'll talk about the lightsaber
resting on the guy disappearing in a
second but that's that's not the thing
so
we didn't set out to make this a star
wars fan film like those aren't supposed
to be lightsabers uh this is not
supposed to be in the star wars universe
at all um it's just we are doing energy
swords and acknowledging how much
cultural weight is behind
energy swords as a figment of star wars
um
but the quarter crew video
more so than the corridor like channel
video the standalone video the quarter
crew video sets it up very much being
our take on lightsabers and trying to
evolve lightsabers some people watch it
they see it as being a star wars video
whereas on the corridor channel and
people watch it there's none of that
like pretense and so they don't
necessarily watch it as being a star
wars video some you know people say
lightsabers because that's kind of
become the colloquial term for like
energy swords but beyond that like
there's not
there's not a whole lot of like well you
know in the star wars universe this
shouldn't be happening in this scene
like there's not a whole lot of that
because i think people are getting that
it's not star wars they're not feeling
that vibe
but even the people who did see it as
star wars and they're saying things like
you know i don't like what you did for
lightsaber sounds i think you need to
stick with the original star wars
lightsaber sounds or you know other
things like that for all the people that
did see it as star wars not a single
person commented on the dude with the
baseball cap
in the scene like that had zero like
effect on anybody as seeing this as
being a part of star wars like
the lightsaber sounds weren't correct
but the guy in the leather jacket and
baseball cap he's cool yeah he's coming
away with it yeah yeah that was kind of
weird like i i i i how many people were
like oh just why does he have a baseball
cap no he's taking back there hasn't
been a single comment from like for
anybody who thought this was a star wars
fan film there hasn't been a single
comment of them questioning why there's
a guy in a baseball cap
and a leather jacket in this room let
alone a janitor with a mop
i've never seen a janitor with a mop in
star wars most of them are droids
so yeah
but i do like the idea of this being in
an alternate reality a different world
where there are things like the
resurrection machines
which is not something you'd have out on
the battlefield with you because it's a
fine-tuned machine it's something you
can keep in a dojo for example or you
know a world where people can go and
they can train martial arts and train
energy swords and heck maybe they're not
even really that useful in the real
world because there's no magic here it's
just a martial art you know a discipline
um
so there's all sorts of cool
worlds that this short exists in and
you know it kind of takes me to one
other thing too which was
not doing a fan film not doing a star
wars thing like we've done so many
videos on
corridor that are based on other ips
it was really fun just to be like i'm
gonna take everything i like from star
wars and that i want to use here and i'm
just gonna make it my own thing and i'm
just gonna call it my own thing and like
that was super liberating and i feel
like we did it in just the right way
where people who are who like star wars
and who are into sword fights and action
and all that kind of stuff
can see the bridge between that that
world and this world
but it's still unique enough that i
think it's a little more thrilling and
exciting yeah and i think it really
shows that for everybody out there who
everyone out there who feels the need to
do a fan film
you can just change things
and just maintain the spirit of that fan
film still and i think it'll still
resonate with everybody else who wants
that
like if you really want to make a piece
about batman
have it all feel like it's a fan film
about batman but just literally just
slightly change batman just slightly
change him and that's all you have to do
and like don't call him batman
and be then suddenly it's 100 years and
like people it feels fresh again and
people come at you without really these
preconceived notions but all the people
who love batman and your love of batman
and that style can still completely
exist in this new realm
um
so that's kind of my new like philosophy
when it comes to
fan films these days and like making
videos about things that inspire me is
just
just take everything out
it's a roundabout uh way of the 80 20
rule yeah
of uh 80 percent
previous context previous creativity 20
new
yeah
it's a good way to not be like super
restrictive in what you can do as well
you know it's like freeing you're not
just like stuck to the original ip it's
like you can you have free reign to do
you know whatever you want within the
bounds of that world definitely and i
think it is in a way exciting like when
you do successfully hit the tone so i
think that's a lot of what it is is
people just really like the tone of like
like take for example peter's spider-man
video that he made like i think he
really likes the idea of you know a
character swinging through buildings and
the tone of a spider-man film that kind
of friendly neighborhood spider-man vibe
um
and it all exists already in the
spider-man world the moment spider-man's
on screen you get it
um
but you could i think these days
especially because of like how prevalent
youtube has been in like you know
creator content and fan films
and all that kind of stuff you can hit
something that is clearly spider-man
just slightly different but clearly
clearly clearly still spider-man and at
this point i think people are like ah
cool let's do it and they just they're
down like i'm down for alternate reality
spider-man his name is spider-boy you
know or whatever like and his costumes
purple and yellow instead of green and
or you know blue and red like that's it
and then everything else is exactly the
same
i think people are actually totally down
for it these days and like that and
heck if it blows up now you have your
own ip
in addition yeah so
yeah
yeah man no um
two things on that i'm glad that we well
that you got a chance to get out and and
shoot something
um like you know
wholly original yeah um
that's me too you know um
we had we had a lull of that obviously
with last year and then you know with
the way that the crew channel's been
which is still we're exploring new ideas
there constantly
but
we're also
putting them in that particular format
and so it's nice to break it out of that
a little bit
um
and uh yeah i'm excited to do more of
that i'm starting to feel that itch
again yeah like to like make some stuff
and really like make original stuff and
um yeah no i spent uh i spent today part
of today uh just writing out some ideas
for wizard cops the series
so hopefully
you guys like them and uh we can
actually make that a reality
this is a little green green light
teaser by the way yeah has anyone heard
anything about this you're just like
casually dropping that no one yeah i
mean i'm i'm talking about it because
that's like that's uh yeah i'm super
excited about that too because i that's
one of my favorite like corridor videos
yeah well it was funny because
last year
i guess no it was earlier this year
um
i was just kind of like going through
the library and and kind of like what
nico was saying like looking at hey what
what stuff are we doing or have we done
that a people enjoyed it has an element
of originality to it
but it's also got that sort of 80 20
balance and is producible like at us at
a small enough scale
without sacrificing what uh story
and
that one i mean it's got comedy it's got
action it's got magic it's got visual
effects
you can do
through lines with characters you can
you can take it out of the cops you know
like the direct cops where it's just you
don't care about the characters it's
just scenes and interactions you can
expand upon it a little bit with like
interpersonal dialogue between the
characters um but then also still get
all of that like
scene changes the action the sort of
quick pace of it and the bite sizeness
of it you know keeping it like still 20
to 30 minutes
um so yeah um i just like that you don't
have to
worry too much about shot lists because
you just you just shoot it the reality
style that's another amazing thing about
it when we shot the original it was like
wait we have two cameramen okay yeah
just act act out this it was like stage
acting and you guys were just standing
there with the shoulder mounts and the
best thing is the show
that you're drawing the inspiration from
does all they do is shoulder mounted
with a with a light on the camera
like cinematography ever yeah like
that's your setup and it's wobbly and
it's janky and you don't catch
everything all the time and
and it it works because that's what
people are
relating it back to that's what they're
expecting
yeah and you get that like you get that
inspiration driving things like the
office parks and rec what we do in the
shadows
yeah you know all that totally follows
the same vibe
except we get lazier
well i remember when we
conceptualized the first one i believe
you wrote it niko or you and yeah was it
you and andrew or was it just
it was i think it was
mostly me and then andrew really helped
design
the spells and all that kind of stuff
so
when you wrote it the first thing you
said to me was like i was like i want to
write the next episode and you're like
well you kind of need to know dungeons
and dragons
and i was like yeah
yeah and and today i i like fully
realized that because i was sitting
there and i was like okay how do
how is this not just cops with wizards
you know right like how is it wizard
cops like how is it different how is it
different and so i'm i was really
starting to pull out you know like in
the intricacies of the jokes of like hey
you know
this person's caught for like you know
trying to
obtain this contraband or something but
what about that makes it
fantasy wizards rather than just like
this is an illegal drug you know yeah
like thinking thinking of layers deeper
than that and and i was able to get um a
decent start on that so nice well maybe
next week i'll share it with you guys
and uh i'll see how far i get
sweet yeah and you know you got d and d
under your belt now you know
you got you got the experience cause
like it's all about those things like uh
you know like what's the equivalent
whoopsies turn on my flashlight what's
the like what's the equivalent of a
taser in the fantasy realm what's the
equivalent of a warrant
what would somebody be trying to steal
you know if it's not money you know gold
coins what are drugs what do they do to
you uh when it's in the fantasy realm
and then of course
always revisiting the the tropes we
already know and spinning on those just
a little bit like what's a little spin
you can do on you know not only the cops
tropes but all the fantasy tropes
so
that's actually something that uh tanner
and um
[Music]
uh
was it brian
yeah brian
brian yeah i think it's i think it's
brian
uh tanner and brian were the two cops
and they did some really solid improving
um
like half the stuff that half the
dialogue is them just playing
brian mcgowan brian mcgowan yep yeah uh
and i think it's another big thing is
like just getting people in that could
just do the whole improv sketch thing
and just have them happy
those two
and i think tanner especially like brian
was great too but tanner has that like
sort of like
dad vibe
to him you know and he can like he can
he's really witty and quick with his
stuff
and he's a great actor
man he he was so good in the first one
it'd be it would be awesome to bring him
back i don't know what he's up to these
days but
yeah be really fun
yep
also you know one other thing that i'm
i've been thinking about is like
there is it's undeniable there's a draw
in the business you can get names
in your pieces right you feel like you
have a certain actor people go see it
um totally
i wonder how much we can do the same
thing with like online personalities
like if you did wizard cops but you had
like
each episode the people that make like
the 911 call or whatever the wizard
equivalent of that is
um
we need to have we need to have freddie
be a bad guy
yeah
but you know you have you have different
you know different police stories except
you just you get different like famous
youtube comedians like play out the
different roles and stuff yeah totally
we should totally do that
yeah definitely ups viewership for sure
yeah you just have their whole audience
now wanting to come watch it that's the
reason like all these blockbuster movies
they're getting all these influencers
from instagram being the main actors and
you're like i don't even know they could
act and they're like yeah
[Music]
they can't they can't sometimes they
can't yeah yeah sometimes they still
can't they just bring all the people
says the influencers
this is the influencer who is acting i i
proved i could act so
yeah
yeah comments don't lie
youtube
this might be too nerdy but like a thing
that i also
was trying to lay into on this in the
script was
the department the cops
are wizards like they're not they're not
just like
any type of
magi creature right they're like
specifically wizards they're
specifically wizards yeah so i was
thinking you could have a controversy
throughout the script where like there's
some debate about like bringing in other
types of beings into the department and
they're like oh gosh but we're all
wizards and like
like some through lines like that um
yeah
i got to this one i got to this one
point where i was like okay they're
gonna breach a door and then my first
instinct was like okay they need a ram
but then
i was like no they don't a wizard would
never use a friggin ram to breach a door
like that's the most unwizard cop thing
ever
um so anyways i'm having all these
revelations i just need to get them off
my chest
[Laughter]
i mean you know how i how i would have
the wizards reach right
i'd have them set up at the door and
then the one guy steps up with his paint
which is probably lamb's blood uh so
maybe they even like or like a chicken
blood so they'd like literally like
slaughter the chicken right there they
paint the rune on the door they step
back they touch it with like their two
fingers whisper the magic incantation
the door shatters and blows inwards they
rush into the room and then the door
pieces then reassemble themselves back
into the door that's almost exactly
that's almost exactly what i wrote
except for the instead of blood i was
using gold dust oh great
wonderful wow
yeah and how do you know to do that
so there's actually like there's a deep
lore of like wizard action that like i
have at least been working on in my head
for the past six years
um because i've been really wanting to
do like some more like a gritty fantasy
like fighting um yeah i even wrote this
like
12 page long script at the beginning of
the year here that never
never turned into an actual good story
so i never made anything but like jake
and i have talked about this sam and i
have talked about this like we've all
been bouncing this around but like i've
really been wanting to do like a wizard
swat thing and it's not like not goofy
but like
if you had like
four or five like tactical operators
that but they're using magic basically
like in the world of harry potter what
does the swat team look like like not a
funny swap team a real swat team that
would use that kind of stuff that's
going up against magical criminals and
stuff like what would their tools look
like what would their tactics be like
you know
none of this stuff that's an interesting
story though
that one's way more in line with like
your style i think i i i lean more into
like the whimsical like situational
comedy yeah none of that's like he's
like saying like no that stuff is
actually a story that's just like a
setting um
but yeah wizard cops is definitely a
much more goofier version that though i
do like the idea that if they have to
call the wizard swat they take
themselves we should we should do a swat
episode within the season
and they're just like
holy [ __ ]
yeah the battle mages show up yeah yeah
from another from another plane they
call in battle mages from another plane
yeah okay i'm gonna okay
i just i also i just it's really also
fun to explore like modern day issues
through that lens you know like what
does it descend like police look like
yes that's like all awcab
you know
it's like all that stuff exists here too
but it's like it gives you that
opportunity to to like
you know
do comedy with it a little bit you know
because that's that's how we get through
that stuff is like you gotta figure out
what's the analysis
jake what's the wizard cops equivalent
of like the punisher skull with the
bluetooth
oh dude
that's a great question blue line
punisher skull yeah probably like a it's
a thin blue line it's but instead of the
line it's a it's a it's a
staff or not a staff a one wizard wand
it's a wand yeah
it's a blue wand it's just a thin blue
lion
yeah a very malnourished one
yeah
yeah jordan in in in like dungeons and
dragons pulls on this but like there's
this idea when you're casting certain
spells that are like beyond just you
know like your level one spells where
you need to have like a gesture involved
or like a material involved otherwise
the magic won't work
um i don't know where this stuff comes
from i mean i imagine it goes all the
way back to like you know actual
like human history and carrying it
forward in storytelling but
yeah um that's that's why like well of
course you need you need lamb's blood or
gold dust to open a door yeah like i
would have no idea material plane when
he was like well you know what i would
use and i'm like
you don't open these doors with lamps
obviously we would cut a chicken right
in front of it i'm like okay
you guys were saying earlier you're
pulling from d and d so is that a d and
d thing well d and d pulls from all of
that stuff yeah yeah it's not like it's
not like
well d does have uh like spells like
somatic components
verbal components basically in other
words and they've simplified this in
fifth edition but like 3.5 is kind of
all the stuff you should speak where
each spell had three components e uh and
any combination thereof either you had
to say something you had to move a
certain way or you had to have a certain
amount of something to cast a spell or
any combination thereof so maybe you
need a pinch of dry grass you need to
whisper a few words and then you can
cast like wind wall or something like
that and but the thing that came out of
that is that other players would have
things like a silence spell and they
could cast out an area and create
silence meaning any spells that required
a verbal component couldn't be cast
because your words wouldn't exist and
that's where like if you ever played
like final fantasy the spell silence is
a pull from dungeons and dragons because
the closest you get to an anti-magic
spell is a silence spell because they
can't whisper the magic words yeah okay
cool interesting
see we need to do that i did my first
tabletop game
but it was alien yeah so c mike uh
dm'd a uh game for us yeah um
i saw some pics of that and griffin um
and it was yeah it was all alien themed
and it's a lot of fun it's actually a
lot of fun we just started the campaign
like a week ago but we have like 15 more
hours to go
[Laughter]
i'm down
let's go let's go it can we uh can we
talk about the
the the two most uh most prevalent
comments i think i've seen in a video
ever yes
uh the sun disappears and the lightsaber
rests on kendall's chest
actually can we do the sunday spheres
first because i
when i edit when i went through because
i i did a pass of the cut um after nico
did a couple of passes um
didn't notice that
really i didn't notice that no and you
know why it's because the
the point of the editing in that scene
was the the pace of the fight so i'm
paying attention to the actual fight and
how it's all being cut together and not
the sun in the background everyone else
who is just a casual audience member
that's not actually editing it right
they're just watching it right passively
so of course they're gonna see
everything right but like the yeah the
the whole reason i was going through
this pass was to
um you know yeah to figure out those
details of the actual fight yeah and of
like how it was intercut and there were
so many people watching it for him like
they saw him there there's so many like
comments about him so their eyes are
focused on him rather than like sure
that's the guy from bone works
[Laughter]
my point is though that i totally agree
with your choice because i'm sure you
knew i knew from date well yeah i knew
the moment we shot the shot
with up right in it because
we at the if you saw the quarter crew
video we have this one really long take
where they go through the entire
sequence of choreography at the end of
the day which
is amazing that they did it as clean as
they did in that one long take um but we
did that twice in the so we're like
we're at the end of the day we're all
done shooting and looks like let's do
one long take i'm like yeah heck yeah
let's do it and we did it and brett
wasn't there because the end of the day
we had like we had basically said that's
a wrap um
and we did it and they just they nailed
it they were so good it was the curious
part it was like oh man like once you
put away all the acting and like and
they've had a whole day of just doing
this and they just run through it it's
like it was the best choreo i had filmed
the entire day
and i was like okay we do that one more
time we need to get brett back in and
then we did it again
but
i'm gonna pick out the best takes and
there's two moments that were just the
best both from like the camera work and
the acting and the choreo that were from
that take when brett wasn't there
and part of me is like i could always
put brett back in the shot
or i could just not worry about it
don't worry about it
you should go full george lucas and
release uh an updated cut where you put
him in the background yeah and you know
i figured not everybody would notice i
mean it's true like matt didn't even
notice anything no i didn't i did it
again yeah and i i just did my
profession
i did not jordan didn't notice either
this is actually the first time for some
reason i didn't even see that comment
about brett not being there anymore well
you know obviously you brought it up
because you were talking about like you
should we should add we'll either add
them back in or yeah i mean you should
have seen the list of vfx though yeah
there's a lot yeah that's that's the
other thing like you know now going to
the the next comment the next big one
which is
the lightsaber
when it was lined up purposely not
purposely
did you guys do it on purpose did you
not the lightsaber on his chest kendall
just happened to fall that way well yeah
actually back it up a little bit you
know the lightsabers they're supposed to
turn off when you stop holding them
but that requires us to paint out like
we had the prop on set it was casting
light and he dies in that shot and we'd
have to somehow paint up the light we
have to paint out the sticks so
also
like the the actual like lightsaber is
it's like at an angle right so it would
then have to be we'd have to figure out
how to adjust it yeah it would just
make any sense to yeah so we'd record
the shot with him holding the the
lightsaber on and that's just kind of
how he fell over because at the end of
the day once again we're running out of
time to get the rest of our shots
and
there came a moment to decide in the in
the edit in post do we want to put
visual effects on that shot or not like
not necessarily paying out the sword but
we want to have it like start sizzling
as it like cuts through his body
and it opens up this can of worms with
like the revive shot that happens next
the amount of damage on his key and also
it would be it's i know it's distracting
as it is currently but it'd be even more
distracting if he brought attention to
it with like sizzles and less layers and
smoke yeah we have to have all this like
sparky like you know lens flare flashing
and stuff that would just you know the
whole point of that scene is
the student just won like you're trying
to turn everyone's direction to that and
everyone's like wait hold on yeah
samer and at the end of the day it's
like there's so many movies that we all
love that we grew up loving that we even
love now that have blatant errors
uh and we just if we love the movie we
don't worry about it and that's kind of
at the end of the day what the kind of
the running ethos is was for this it's
like
brett disappearing for a moment in a
shot in the background or
uh kendall dropping lightsaber across
his body at the end of the fight neither
of those things
made the story not work neither of those
things were like
huge mistakes that pulled you out and
that's i know for some people it did
pull them out to have the lightsaber
touch them and not cut through them
um
you know it's funny though is if he
would have dropped it on the ground
would that have mattered at all in terms
of like probably not
well
my assumption is that if you dropped it
on the ground people not as many people
would have said much but right yeah they
think about the lightsabers they
probably burn through the ground i mean
if you take if you take star wars as
your cannon
you can stab those things into like
ships
and into doors remember obi-wan stabs
one into a door and then melts it
yeah
yeah so it just helps just say it from
touching though nowhere a little bit
probably but yeah either way
i don't know
um it's also it's kind of interesting
the the contrast between making like a
cinematic film for youtube versus like a
theater or a streaming platform can you
ima can you imagine if there were
comments on streaming platforms like
netflix yeah they'd be like no no we got
to fix this right now yeah exactly yeah
yeah big studio heads would be like hold
on we got to make some changes
there's a reason why there's no comments
on netflix yeah
but you know if like if at the end of
the day
everybody liked the piece and enjoyed it
then is it really that big of a deal
that brent just appeared for a minute or
that kendall dropped the lightsaber yeah
we could have fixed it with like days
more of work
but
i just i would rather shoot another
episode of the vfx artist react or get
home earlier and have dinner with ivy
and milo or you know or whatever like i
i love making this stuff but at a
certain point i want to be putting my
efforts
or i'm assuming the same for you matter
jordan anybody else here you want to put
your efforts into the stuff that matters
and that's always a gray area but at a
certain point it's like if this isn't
bringing joy if this isn't making
somebody excited if this isn't making
the scene better or more emotionally
intense if it's just me fixing an error
to the point where if i do my job
correctly nobody will even notice it at
all and as it currently is it doesn't
detract from the piece like that's
you're almost wasting your time at that
point
yeah so that's definitely that's why we
decided to just leave those errors in
there and
the other big reason that's only 50 of
the reason the other big reason
is that by leaving two
glaring issues
that aren't so glaring as to detract
from the piece like the p still works
it's great you enjoy it it's
entertaining it's got the story it's got
the emotion it's got all those things
but there's two clear these clear little
things that everybody can see that are
technically mistakes by leaving those in
we've probably got twice as many
comments and twice as much audience
engagement than if they weren't if those
things weren't there at all there's also
that there's also the old client rule
which is if you leave in a mistake
people will notice that and not the
other ones
[Laughter]
exactly yeah you're sending client uh
work to a client for them to uh you know
give you notes on you leave one glaring
problem so that's what they put their
notes into versus like them scrutinizing
work that you've put hours and hours
into making perfect and they pick that
up obvious
yeah
we did we did have to fix the nipples
though we didn't fix the nipples
that was in the vfx spreadsheet those
nipples one of them it was called nips
out which is the name of the shot
i don't know this shot
so the this
is the student
actually
jordan would you like to explain
what because i know where i cut the hole
it's the holes the hole though is way
lower
though than yes so okay
so
basically we just got a title for this
episode it nips out so the hole i made
no
actually unfortunately the hole that you
cut um which you cut some great holes
you did a great job with those holes um
unfortunately one of them was directly
on his nipple when he was standing up
and the other one is almost on his other
nipple because he gets stabbed in his
stomach
it was it very much looked like he had
two cut out like purple holes you know
what happened is when i was cutting
those holes i put it on myself
and was like trying to figure it out
because he was out there already in the
other d and i was like i can't go grab
him like they need them on set and then
i go to start putting it on him okay
yeah i already knew it was kind of tight
but didn't realize yeah that was so so
what needed to happen because that i
think in with vfx like that that are
like you know just fixing glaring
problems it's like you got to pick your
battles you know you gotta be like what
is the more distracting thing or what is
the thing that's gonna like detract from
the story oh my god
right over here i couldn't imagine if
that was in the whole thing he's dead
and he pops up and he's just got the
nipples hanging out it's the scene where
he bows
it's the scenery bows and then um sorry
he's finishing bowing in the the guy his
the mat the teacher walks up and gives
him a hug or whatever after he's been
repeating it's a very important story
moment yeah that
shouldn't have been detracted by his
nipples and what should have been a hole
for continuity of him getting stabbed
which is like there's still another hole
on there that works but that's why the
holes are there for continuity of his
hand
i wonder how many moments like that like
say you know say you have a sword fight
in real life right and it's like okay
there's this heroic moment and this
person beats somebody else and it's like
you know it's like this medieval like
event
and then the person stands up and
instead of it being like in the movies
where everything's perfect and it's like
okay they don't have holes on their
nipples like they do how many times has
that happened where it's like
some hero
has stood a lot and had that happen i
mean people lose like their clothing and
fights all the time
right which is very like very primal and
like raw but like that's not what movies
are like
right no
way too distracting yeah
yeah well but long story short well
actually it was still a pretty long
story about nipples we just had to
remove we literally just removed the
painted out the nipple parts yeah in the
hole and that was that
yeah i think yeah that's like a pick
your battles thing there's also like at
the end of the like the last day of vfx
when we were wrapping it all up um you
know obviously there was the lightsaber
on the chest but i had a little bit of
time to do something else and it wasn't
going to be like adding a little smoke
or something to that it didn't seem to
bother me either and definitely not niko
um but one thing that i did want to do
was add a flash from that revive machine
uh when we cut to you
right so like little things like that i
feel like are more important than you
know trying to fix some lightsaber
options yeah and if you're commenting
about the lightsaber on the chest yo
check this out we shot that in two
locations and
you know you probably didn't even notice
that jordan and the headmaster are at an
entirely different location and when we
cut to those shots where it's ots on
jordan that's not even jordan
that's nice
jordan
people fight i'm looking at a wall
that's right so you just got to
yeah yeah
and we built that wall yeah that's the
one i'm standing in front of you
you and christian did you guys did a
great job with that it totally sold it
it does it looks the same it looks like
i forget that we're in two different
locations yeah i'm a big fan of the door
gig like the door opens and he walks in
and it's just a light
yes it's just a light and i'm like
acting surprised every time it's just
you walking by oh yeah yeah by the way
that's also not the
yeah the student
me and the student were never in a scene
together you walked by
i think you flashed the light i think
christian did or was it christian yeah
christian flashed the light to act like
the front door was opening
it's all just smoke and mirrors yeah
it's all just building blocks they're
just making a very fancy picture book
that's that's what yeah they all were
doing yep yeah
at 24 frames a second or 30.
yep
all right man well well there you have
it
lightsabers to the death it was it was
very very wonderful seeing all the
comments and reception from it
at least for me the
the happiest i am as a filmmaker is on
the day of film releases and then seeing
people be like this was cool i like this
it makes me want more i'm imagining what
could happen next and people are like
writing out their own stories or even
you know people like being like you know
you lost me in this moment or whatever
it doesn't matter like the fact that
there's so many people so inspired to
like write uh comments and you know
share their
their emotions from like what the piece
made them feel the fact that made
anybody feel anything
uh is super super cool and like it was
just it was a showcase i think of like a
bunch of talent from so many different
talented people
um so yeah it was like super super
fulfilling i it was a wonderful weekend
i had a great time oh yeah my saturday
was
i was on cloud nine and my sunday i mean
my sunday it didn't come out saturday
came out sunday i had a good saturday
too for what it's worth
all right
well
i think that means we need to go back
over those hills and closer to where we
came from
all right before we get over and far
away
maybe a place where jordan and i know
the lyrics of the scene yeah
yeah wait no you gotta play the rock and
roll part that kicks in
okay let me see if i know
it i have to play the whole thing to get
there
[Music]
i don't remember it i don't remember
he sounds like a chipmunk so
yeah
well cool
i definitely you guys have definitely
encouraged me to know
wait hold on is that on led zeppelin two
or four is it over the hills and far
away remastered 1973 that means it's on
led zeppelin ii
i believe
all no all right people are sitting here
listening
to 1973 jordan listen to that one too
all right
album
the song remains the same it's their
fifth album okay there you go song
yeah okay or heck do their live album
while the west is one that has it on
there amongst others it's very good all
right all right thanks for listening to
the podcasting off
bye guys